merci d'avoir appliqué sur cette vidéo
je vais pas passé par quatre chemins à
part les deux chiens d'animaux de chiba
une bonne fois pour toutes mais je suis
en colère
pourquoi je suis en colère parce que
vous m'avez nommée égérie chiba de
france mais j'ai jamais demandé ça j'ai
juste adopter un schéma parce que
j'adore ça tout le monde mais on voit
tout le temps ces petites vidéos de
chiba à droite à gauche même mes amis
regardez ce que freddy koella dieu m'a
envoyé il ya quelques jours c'est juste
une vidéo de chiba quand les chiens dont
il ne se passe rien il a jugé pertinent
gaiement dans votre tête je suis un
malade mental des chiba et c'est
peut-être vrai oui vous savez j'adore
les chiba plus particulièrement le mien
maintenant journée en dessous une
blessure d'amour depuis quelques temps
vous le savez vous voyez vous voyez
non-stop sur instagram
alors écoutez apparemment vu je suis
l'égérie de chiba en france aujourd'hui
on va parler de chiba je vais vous
parler de plein de trucs et ensuite on
va essayer des de chengdu des
de trucs qui se passent dans des
vidéos vous m'envoyer par millions sur
natsu et vous allez voir que ça sert à
rien d'envoyer ses vidéos là puisque
quand je veux que notre surface pareil
tu fais l'opposé c'est bon premièrement
alors la première malheur elle est gelée
reçus au moins 1300 points sans exagérer
alors j'avoue qu'à vidéo en question
c'est très fort c'est un maître qui
montre à son chiba des photos de lui en
train de faire quelque chose soit d'être
couché soit des taties soit donnée la
pâte et le chiva reproduit l'action qui
voit sur la photo ce qui est fou jordan
manche est même pas que c'était possible
alors vous savez quoi commençons avec
celui-là je ramène natsu je le prends en
photo en train très différentes actions
et on voit si réagi quand je le montre
les photos
la réponse est non c'est évident mais au
moins vous arrêterez de m'envoyer cette
vidéo match tu viens alors qu'est ce
qu'il y là encore squeeze tu sais qui
arrivait de la police va toujours à
m'utiliser pour buzz et sur youtube
alors assez bien sûr ça s'est couché la
honte
immédiatement la ont d'entrée de jeu
donc ok ah c'est ok pas bougé
[Musique]
donc là j'apprends la photo de candide
est assis couché quand il donne la page
je vais lui montrer la photo de camden
la pâte et on va voir s'il réagit plutôt
obg
ouais mais ça ouais mais ça compte pas
parce que quand je lui tends la main il
me donne tout un patron serge pas alors
la photo il est couché mondiaux je me
fais déjà chier hajime coucher
tout du ouf ça marche il a reconnu la
photo si ça peut te faire me donnait
plus j'ai de croquettes aller à l'enjeu
le monde celle où il est assis par
contre faut pas pousser non plus
s'il avait la couperie aulas là bas tu
vois je pensais pas que ça marcherait
quel challenge incroyable c'est pas si
dur finalement vous avez eu raison
d'envoyer la vidéo
comprenez là où je veux en venir
maintenant bon en vrai je trouve ça
vraiment impressionnant la vidéo mes
parents je pense que c'est un fait je
pense vraiment qu'il ya quelqu'un qui
est à gauche de la personne qu'on voit
et qui donne les instructions aux chiens
à l'oral et du coup il réagi à ça et
réagit pas à la vision des photos
d'ailleurs on voit bien à son regard qui
regarde pas du tout téléphone mais qui
regardent soit le visage de la personne
qui tient téléphone soit le visage de
quelqu'un d'autre qui est derrière la
personne bref tout ça n'est que
supercherie vous êtes 15 villes à avoir
re tweeté une supercherie et au moins
mille âmes l'avoir envoyé à moi ou plus
moi j'aurais honte à votre place bon
deuxième vidéo que voilà on my home as
juste avant celle ci d'ailleurs elle
elle est sortie je crois en fin d'année
dernière et je crois qu'il ya encore des
gens aujourd'hui qui me l'envoie parce
qu'il vient seulement de tomber dessus
c'est le sne août challenge qui consiste
à faire en sorte que toshiba pose son
nez là où tu le veux ou mettre sa truffe
là où tu le veux c'est la classe alors
il ya un problème à ce niveau-là c'est
que natsu a peur d'enfiler des choses
autour de son cou c'est pour ça que
d'ailleurs je mets un collier et par
harnes et là alors il n'y a plus que des
gens qui ont déchiré l'acquérir cette
vidéo on est d'accord on peut parler de
choses sérieuses on a perdu la moitié
les gens là tous ses combats d'animaux
ce chao ils comprennent plupart ont la
truffe dans le rond c'est possible il ya
une autre version de ce challenge où tu
fais juste ça et que tes doigts et où le
chiva vient poser son museau ici aucun
moyen qu'on réussisse allez allez on
teste j'ai même pas quand j'aimerais
cette vidéo je teste des gros challenge
de merde sur mon chien passe tu vas à
tous à l'aller il vient même pas quand
je l'appelle comme on veut qu'il vienne
quand je fais un rond s'en fout ce que
vous voyez là c'est typique du chiva il
a fait l'effort une fois il a vu que
c'est pas très amusant du coup il a
exactement
tac la pause oui j'ai vu pourquoi tu
fais un angle avec tes doigts
moi j'ai un peu je vais venir le truc à
lui vous avez compris attentions
auxquelles il faut donner la patte
ah merde en fait c'est l'autre bah non
c'est bien celle-ci masse la truffe
bon je vais attendre allongé il sera
content ce qu'on en fait j'ai c'est de
désensibiliser au vu de mettre sa truffe
dans les doigts mais ils en vivaient les
choux et bien oui c'est un nouvel échec
mon petit chien mais c'est normal je
n'ai jamais appris l'étoile alger la
caresse alors que j'ai été nul à chier
messieurs dames maintenant le challenge
qui ils aggravent marché un peu comme le
what the fall of the challenge que j'ai
fait sur nos installations tu disparais
de couverture mois la très pittoresque
de haine dit bolt shalem qui se fait à
l'aide de papier cellophane donc le truc
christique invisible conductrice pour
conserver les plats on met le chiba de
l'autre côté d'une porte et à l'entrée
de la porte on met du papier cellophane
et on ouvre la porte et le chien doit
nous rejoindre de l'autre côté de la
porte malgré le fait qu'ils aient un
double papier cellophane
alors j'ai vu des gens réagir mal à ce
challenge or non mais attends ça se fait
trop pas les amis il n'est pas blessé il
a rien au contraire c'est hyper
intéressant de voir quelle réaction ton
chien va avoir face à cette pseudo
épreuve on parle juste d'un papier
transparent c'est assez intéressant
reste où il n'a pas compris le piège des
taux
tout est en place c'est parti la vie de
ma mère ça sent le traquenard ton
histoire intime on a tous ratés l'a fait
- heurts - poursuit la pop comme
d'habitude je m'allongeais fini par être
content j'ai l'impression que c'est un
péché car une fois de plus c'est soit
faire je vais laisser la porte ouverte
avec salah et on va voir s'il a
abandonné se décide à rentrer puis peut
toujours attendre quoi mourir mais oui
c'est intéressant voir à quel point il a
peur de l'inconnu qui risquent rien n'y
a aucun danger là mais comme il connaît
pas il veut pas se mouiller il attend
tout simplement que je prenne et que je
le porte et que je le met là avec moi
comme je fais d'habitude à la moindre
épreuve parce que je suis un maître gaga
passion doc à la suite de la vidéo ça
vous tue des remarques on a fait tous
ces petits challenge là que vous vouliez
voir un depuis très longtemps déjà
peut-être réussir le dernier d'ici 20
jours je vais vous montrer mes vidéos
préférées de chiba parce que vous m'en
voyez pas que des challenge m'envoyait
aussi des vidéos normal de chiba mignon
comme freddy a fait et je veux aussi
vous dévoiler mon petit secret juste
après ça m'est déjà regardons ces
petites vidéos là déjà il ya ce chiba
trop connu qui est en fait une sorte de
kiosque qui vend des cigarettes des
friandises du bonbon des petits trucs
sérieux une toute petite échelle et le
vendeur c'est nul autre qu'un chiba et
oui du coup il ya plein de touristes qui
vont à ce petit choc parce qu'il est
trop mignon c'est un chiba qui se tient
là à la place du vendeur pour bien
entendu quand tu fais ta commande c'est
pas le schéma qui de file des objets 1
c'est le vendeur ya derrière d'ailleurs
j'y suis jamais allé alors je fais
plusieurs fois au japon je suis un peu
dingue mais voilà c'est un truc trop
connu là bas on va dire que c'est le
sixième truc que j'ai le plus reçu de
tout ce que vous m'envoyez à propos des
schémas ce qui est pas mal
après ça alors celui-là quand il
est sorti de celui-là je pense que c'est
le number 3 que j'ai le plus de succès
ainsi baky et tourne autour d'une clim
parce qu'il a attiré par un truc qui
bouge qui est en fait le bout de sa
laisse carolla son collier fait ça
pendant genre vraiment longtemps sous
les rires impitoyable de sa maîtresse
c'est terrible quelle humiliation et
enfin et là je vous dévoile mon petit
secret c'est un peu le même effet que
ceux qui adorent des artistes qui sont
pas très connus et quand ils deviennent
médias populaires ils se mettent à plus
les aimer du tout envie que ce soit un
truc avec pas une trop une énorme
communauté qui soit ton petit truc à toi
c'est trop bizarre
shiv neige chaîne youtube de 405
blatter au sol son challenge c'est que
des de vidéos chiba et c'est
trop drôle et c'est génial il ya deux
vidéos en particulier que j'adore mais
que je serai pas là dessus puisque c'est
un peu bâtarde cd vidéo qui s'appelle
bonne douzaine qui me dit rembobinez et
en gros il ya deux vidéos comme ça sur
la chaîne ou bâle la personne en bobine
son chien le trail et ça m'a brisé le
coeur
donc là le but c'est de trouver dans
quelles mains et la croquette pour le
chien c'est un jeu très connu qui
stimule ton chien qui coule
[Musique]
il n'y avait pas de croquettes aucune
croquettes dans aucune main regardez moi
le regard de cette boîte qui se sent
trahi confuse qui réalise à quel point
elle s'est fait duper par son propre
maître vous rendez vous compte de la
gravité de cet acte c'est fou il est
parti ou nat le plus loin tu attends
gallien ou là bas pour pouvoir sortir sa
vie dont tu es très perspicace
aujourd'hui c'est un maître qui parle à
son chien guide ont fait une voix
bizarre et vidéo pour qu'ils réagissent
mieux
ça ne marche pas bon la deuxième qui est
extraordinaire parce que le setup a dû
demander une vraie préparation de la
part du maître lemaitre est vraiment
très motivé pour humilier son chien
après c'est des petites blagues c'est
comme si tu prends qu'est un pod voilà
des fois ça arrive ça fait marrer bas là
il fait pas avec son chien c'est
incroyable regardez bien
[Musique]
il a creusé une cavité il a laissé une
couche de neige suffisamment fine pour
qu'elle se casse sous le poids de chiba
et qu'il tombe et il a appâté avec un
bol de conquête c'est démoniaque
bon rassurez-vous simard a bien un petit
extrait la de l'huile qui mangent des
croquettes et en prime quelques chose
qu'on adore voir une chute qui n'est pas
doué ce chien du tout et enfin jéhovah
et d'une dernière chose qui est
incroyable parce que bon que je
connaissais déjà longuement parlé mais
y'a pas longtemps je suis tombé sur des
révélations qui m'ont bouleversé à
jamais à chico bah oui vous connaissez
quasiment tous et le film hachey
d'ailleurs qui retrace l'histoire de
hachiko et de son maître hachey causé
par un schéma et nous c'est un acquis
time tout ce qui ressemble fortement à
chiba et douchez d'accord avec vous sauf
que c'est beaucoup plus grand ça fait
genre trois fois le poids d'un chiba
voire quatre fois et les toiles chez
cauet les médias connus mais je vous la
fais rapidement c'est un chien qui
allait à la gare tous les jours à la
même heure pour retrouver son maître qui
rentrait du travail oit il
l'accompagnait à la guerre le matin il
allait chercher le soir le chef
incroyable sauf qu'un jour son maître
est mort ce sont le travail et du coup à
chico continuer de se rendre à la gare
de shibuya où il espérait voir son
maître revenir enfin du travail sauf que
jamais revenus puisqu'il était décédé et
donc à chico s'est rendu tous les jours
à la gare de shibuya en espérant
retrouver son maître pendant plusieurs
années je crois six ou sept ans au total
ce qui est digne d'une loyauté
extraordinaire et donc c'est devenu un
vrai symbole au japon d'ailleurs à la
gare de shibuya la fameuse statue érigée
en son honneur la statue de hachiko et
donc il ya quelques jours je faisais des
recherches sur l'histoire de chico et
sert à des petits détails qui sont
peut-être pas spécifié dans l'histoire
très connu et je vois quoi à chico a été
empaillé
il ne repose pas du tout on perd vexe
outre il est en paillers est exposé au
musée national de la nature et des
sciences de tokyo
on l'a en paille et je trouve ça
incroyable moi je pensais qu'il l'avait
mis dans la tombe de son maître qui
reposaient tous les deux ensemble à tout
jamais la fin de l'histoire était
magnifique hall en paille on le met dans
un musée pour gagner de l'argent grâce à
sa loyauté c'est bon sujet ça va
vraiment fait quelque chose tu veux
retrouver ça horrible s'il vous plaît si
un jour je meurs n'en paient pas nature
non pas y ait pas de match et bien
écoutez avis et la fois la vidéo la plus
gaga youtube qui ampute comporte un
comprimé de micro pendant la moitié
voire les deux tiers de celle ci je suis
désolé je me suis lâché j'ai rattrapé
tous les mois la ne pas parler de chiens
avec des gens puisque j'ai aucun pote
qu'un chien j'en profite aussi
pour passer un petit message sur tout ça
parce que cheikh avec mes vidéos avec
mon histoire avec natsu etc j'ai dû
donner
envie à beaucoup de gens d'adopter un
chien voire un chiba vous savez jamais
ce qui est des campagnes formidable de
lutte contre l'abandon qui sont bien en
place notamment par la fondation 30
millions d'amis est d'ailleurs la
dernière est très bien faite fait
vraiment attention avant d'adopter un
animal que ce soit un chat ou un chien
ya cent mille animaux abandonnés chaque
année ces énormes dont 60 mille juste en
était donc s'il vous plaît sensibiliser
les gens autour de vous un animal c'est
pas un objet c'est pas un accessoire de
mode qu'on jette quand on n'en veut plus
on parle d'êtres vivants qui ont des
besoins énormes qui vont vous prendre
beaucoup de temps vous allez devoir
faire des sacrifices pour eux comme par
exemple partir moins en vacances voire
ne plus partir en vacances du tout même
si vous avez personnes pour le garder
aucun ami si vous n'êtes pas l'argent
pour mettre en pension si vous n'avez
pas tout ça fendrait faut penser à tout
ça comprend un animal ça entraîne des
frais ça entraîne des changements de
quotidien ça entraîne des imprévus ça
entraîne des dépenses imprévues donc
voilà c'est important de le dire parce
que je sais que je donne envie aux gens
faisant des vidéos comme ça et ça me
fait plaisir de faire ces vidéos là mais
je veux pas avoir des milliers d'
abandon sur le dos parce que j'ai montré
que le côté cool d'avoir un animal est
pas le côté moins cool pour certains que
représentent les contraintes je me pose
à finir cette vidéo on retrouve en
dessous un qui bien sûr a été un de ces
quatre chez toi que je vais abandonner
au bord d'une route squeeze
[Musique]